regardez ces images 24 juillet dernier
une boule de feu a illuminé le ciel du
québec jusqu'en ontario il s'agissait
d'un météore qui a touché seul alors si
ce phénomène qui est très très rare on
va parler de ces chasseurs de météorites
je joue à québec le communicateur
scientifique irrigants bonjour monsieur
d'orient oui bonjour
qui sont ils ces chasseurs de météorites
est ce qu'il s'agit de scientifiques de
férus d'astronomie des collectionneurs
mes instincts en forme de tous et déjà
qu'ils sont hors amateurs d'astronomie
ou si des chirurgies et vitale elle ces
phénomènes qui est très très rare ont pu
avant la chance d'avoir des limites y
était l'occasion aussi un peu partout
dans le monde à chaque année puisqu'en
même un phénomène assez rare c'est quand
même une valeur scientifique et quand on
découvre une météorite une valeur
scientifique de découvrir l'objet à
savoir d'où sa provenance est ce qui est
gênant c'est un morceau de la dass
théorie de commettre pierre meta house
une valeur monétaire qui relie aussi
loin la trouvaille d'une météorite la
wii et au canada lorsqu'une météorite
est retrouvé à qui appartient tel est la
personne propriétaire du terrain ces
derniers ont fait le 20e anniversaire de
migrants découverte de métiers prennent
montréal trêve serait de 25
on découvrait le plusieurs métiers au
risque d'un des derniers jours on
aimerait bout phénomène en ontario et
quelques jours par la suite d'une main
phénomène hengbart même retrouvé une
météorite de plus de 15 kilos de la
halle au 25 juillet c'est très très rare
éventuellement aussi donc ce sont des
images la rue 6 à 7 en 2013
encore là donc c'était
l'été elle qui avait touché terre il ya
vu à peu près je pense 1500 blessés
ça arrive très très rarement parce que
généralement météo voit ce qu'on peut
dire disparaître dans l'atmosphère oui
contrairement à l'étoile filante comme
dans les prochaines semaines auront la
chance de voir des persil pour la chance
de voir un beau phénomène en ciel mais
il faut voir qu'une étoile filante et
répétitif à bruz dans la haute
atmosphère
quand est ce qu'un objet comme une
météorite vraiment un objet de fort
diamètre puis quand le gérant dans la
haute atmosphère yb reviennent partout
de l'objet qui peut tomber pile d'amal
les envols on trouve le plus dans le
monde c'est beaucoup pour l'envié pour
se sont cassé les dents si ici au québec
ce serait que plus de 95% des gens qui
trouvent des métiers reçoit les gens qui
travaillent dans les champs
parce que quand on découvre une
météorite sermonne roche qui peu banale
horse une roche qui traiterait laredo va
si mal
ouais ben c'est vraiment très très noir
et très lo c'est très aimante et puis
vraiment nous sommes très particulière
qui fait toute une découverte que vous
avez parlé de l'aspect bon état tout à
l'heure les météorites peuvent être
vendus aux enchères
oui le prix peut différer tout dépendant
de la roche dans la vie correct on va
trouver
oui tout dépendant la provenance une
roche qui vient de nas théorie d'une
comète
ça peut valoir le timide alors la grande
finale andy ram aux affaires est
facilement et si on trouve une roche
encore beaucoup plus rendre un ancien
roches lunaires une ancienne roche de
marche quand c'est très rare que ça peut
valoir plus de 15 à 20 khz d'alors les
grandes bien en valeur le faire face
devant le très très bien donc on peut
s'imaginer qu'il ya des gens les
chasseurs de météorites se sont dirigés
vers l'ontario pour trouver à tout le
moins donc les fameuses oranges pour
pouvoir après coup les revendre
oui parce que les flamands n'étaient pas
des gens qui font les vaches sont des
professionnels qui vous reçoit depuis de
nombreuses années avec équipé de deux
cars de boussole l'équipe et surtout
détecteur de métal c'est jean reno sont
elles se trouvent et se drape seulement
par le roi en allemand et quand on
retrouve une météorite martienne un
phénomène qu'on n'oublie jamais jamais
il a fait la phénomène qui est très
particulière qu'on a vécu à 25,1 saint
graal préfet le real pour tout
astronomes en terminant on entre dans la
période des perséides à la faute et
c'est dans la nuit du 12 au 13 août pour
avoir plusieurs épouses filante
ce sera fait ce thème les astronomes oui
certainement il voit plusieurs endroits
pour faire de l'observation un peu
partout au québec moi j'invite les gens
se marrent vu que s'en vient on voit une
belle puis toiles filantes puis une
belle activité confère la section du
chêne ici même à québec lors à 20 ans
puis c'est une belle occasion de faire
les frais nomi en famille découvrir un
des plus beaux spectacles et neuf sur
nous offrent évidemment l'observation
des étoiles filantes
l'invitation est lancée merci beaucoup
monsieur gagnant mais ça fait plaisir